i reg good morning Theodore this is
arguably my second most favorite time of
the year
obviously the NFL has kicked off their
five or six weeks in you've got the
baseball playoffs in full swing and
opening night my favorite obviously we
talked about this is springtime because
you got you know the baseball players
reporting to spring training and you've
got the NBA getting ready for the
playoffs so it's exciting time for the
NBA today the number one question to be
answered during the regular season for
you is what which team is going to have
the mental capacity really to knock off
the champs I look at all 30 teams and
there's a couple that comes to mind
obviously I'm seeing one of them tonight
I think the Boston Celtics are
tailor-made now a lot has to happen
obviously
barring major injury to all these teams
Brad Stevens and the Celtics to me are
probably the number one team that could
probably go toe-to-toe with the Golden
State Warriors because of their depth
their youth their ability to switch
their defense but a lot has to happen
Kyrie has to stay healthy a lot of
question marks on Gordon Hayward coming
back from that major injury after Game
one last year but those young guys Jalen
Brown case of Tatum off the bench Terry
Rozier was fantastic the Morris twin
these guys are built Al Horford was an
all-star they have so much depth I think
they're the one team that if they were
able to get to the finals could really
push the Golden State Warriors what is
the one question you have about the
Golden State Warriors yep I know what
you're gonna get from their starting
five but after that I mean undo if you
dollar who's great who's a fantastic
sixth man but he's a year older they're
going to be starting Damian Jones
the guy that really never played an NDA
and now he's getting his start with the
world chance
and how does boogie cousins who I
believe personally is going to have a
fantastic year once he comes back and is
going to settle in but what is going to
be his role well he has accepted role I
mean this is a one-year deal and I'm
sure he's auditioning for a much bigger
contract either with the Warriors or
elsewhere but their depth and but that
was the question mark last year and they
found a way you know to win a
championship but that would probably be
my only thing but again this is all you
know they can't have any major injuries
Steph was hurt but they still found a
way to win a championship and you look
at the Lakers and we've talked about
this with LeBron going there I'm gonna
make it a little bigger picture here for
LeBron to win the MVP and he's the
favorite what kind of season does he
have to have / the Lakers have to have
if the Lakers win this game and find
themselves in the top four in the
Western Conference and the Bron goes for
twenty eight eight and eight that's in
VP because right now I personally have
them maybe the sixth or seventh best
team in the West and I have them
anywhere between 42 to 46 wins but if
Luke Walton finds a way to get these
young guys all on the same page and
playing at a higher clip and they could
win 50 plus games it's all going to be
driven by LeBron James and I think
that's where he could arguably win his
fifth MVP
I like the Lakers depth reg I mean I
think they have a lot of bodies there
I'm not big on you know some of the
older guys they brought in but I get
it's for one year
can that be a big advantage for the
Lakers
you can hew j-- young legs
and coach Walton has been very adamant
about that that he wants to run and you
mix that youth those young legs with a
generational type player like LeBron
James getting easy baskets that's going
to be key the problem I have with the
Lakers is I'm not quite sure they have
enough shooting yeah and for LeBron to
be successful you've got to have
shooters on the edges and around so he
could penetrate collapse the defense and
kick it out a willing passer one of the
all-time great passers but you've got to
have shooters I'm not sure they have
enough shooting I like Anthony Davis
this year for the MVP but I'm just not
sure like the pelicans are kind of
irrelevant and even though they made the
playoffs last year how long do you think
Anthony Davis is in New Orleans just
fine with clutch Sports correct and yes
and so forth LeBron and the bronze group
so you know I'm sure you know around the
water cooler people are talking this
could be his last year I hope it's not
you and I have had this conversation
many of times it's great to have
superstars in smaller markets and
obviously New Orleans is one of the
smaller markets in the NBA but in
today's age with social media you know
fans all are almost a part of the game
and all the talk is what have you done
in a playoff have you wanted
championship and that matters to a lot
of these young guys and building super
teams it's the new thing I hope I hope
he stays in New Orleans but the one foot
in one foot out I could see him not
necessarily with LeBron in LA I could
see him here in Boston they have a lot
of young assets and talent I could see
him playing here with Kyrie in Boston as
well have you heard Kawhi Leonard's last
I have I know collide pretty well I mean
eme from the ie and we're in the
Riverside area and that's the first time
I've really heard that surprise I was
really surprised because you never
really you think about it
they come on all the interviews after
games I don't remember an interview that
he's ever done reg I don't remember
anything he's ever said and he's done a
few like commercials when he was his
time with San Antonio with Tim Duncan
and Tony Parker and Ginobili back in the
day and even in the commercial he really
didn't speak well I heard the laugh
somebody put a little take it back it's
a little creepy I think it'd be is great
around this time around Halloween right
I mean you can put that on my loop where
kids come up to the door just start
playing that that's pretty good right
all right before I let you go somebody
spent some time and put this together
with Kawhi Leonard's laughs to the NBA
theme so on the old theme song with NBC
I don't even know where you sitting at
[Music]
try to get that out of your head today
now have fun I'll talk to you next week
phaidor - I can't wait to get the ball
rolling thank you so much alright that's
Reggie Aloysius for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]